créé à l'initiative d'un particulier en
1984 puis repris par la municipalité au
milieu des années 90 le club le village
de montigny le bretonneux ferme ses
portes pour être entièrement réhabilité
fermeture le 21 décembre prochain pour
douze mois de travaux prévus l'ensemble
a été repensé dans sa globalité
donc c'est à 7 à la va être complètement
disparaître ce qui va nous permettre
d'avoir ici surfer placement à peu près
l'arrivée donc l'arrivée des des
personnes qui vont qui viendront
fréquenté le club village par sept par
ce chemin là et du coup c'est l'activité
quand même tennis et badminton se
retrouvera sur la halle qui sera fermée
donc là le faire mais qui sera ici à la
place des tennis découverts et donc on
retrouvera nos deux terrains tennis et
nos terrains de badminton unal détruites
pour être reconstruite l'objectif est de
moderniser l'ensemble le rendre
accessible aux personnes à mobilité
réduite et l'adapter aux nouvelles
pratiques sportives
voyez que c'est quand même une halle qui
est quand même en mode et a donc il n'y
aura pas que d'énormes travaux de
réfection et surtout une structure
quelques mécènes et qui va nous
permettre de d'avoir ici une activité
donc haye 3 terrain de futsal et des
terrains de paddle sur cette superficie
extérieur unal flambant neuf sera
installée pourrait accueillir terrains
de tennis et de badminton une bande
végétale restera pour des activités de
plein air type beach volley et donc
voilà ça c'est la partie sur lequel
dénonce viendront se greffer les
logements 55 à 60 logements pour lequel
un opérateur sera déterminé avant la fin
de l'été 2020 un investissement total de
6,2 millions d'euros pour la ville le
club le village compte 600 adhérents